I've been trying to sort of consolidate
the day-to-day Trump and use into fewer
segments and I kept putting off the
Trump approval story this week but I
have some interesting demographic
numbers to talk about with you so big
picture Donald Trump's approval rating
has the approval rating has been pretty
close to within the same range for a
while but it's lately trickled up a
little bit here we are looking at the
Gallup daily tracking poll it's a
rolling average of Trump's approval a
couple months ago he had several bottoms
out or bottom outs at 35 34 % recently
he's been getting back to some peaks of
38 or 39 percent in several days pretty
small difference right barely outside of
a shift within the margin of error but
it is a daily rolling average it gives
us a little bit of an idea of what's
going on we've talked about these
committed Trump ideologues before these
are the people that are gonna be with
Trump till the very end
whenever the end is and then we've
talked about other Republicans who seem
to actually be paying attention to what
Trump is doing they have a connection to
the real world
Donald Trump is losing support from two
particular groups of Republicans it's
Republicans with college degrees as well
as Young Republicans
the older uneducated Republicans seem to
disproportionately be making up that
sort of unshakeable base that I've
talked about Donald Trump having now
when I talk about the the educated
Republicans moving away from Trump what
do I mean I mean they've completed a
four-year college degree what do I mean
by younger Republicans are moving away
from Trump I mean Republicans under 50
right and there has to it's logical that
we would see this because these are the
groups that have sort of evident flowed
in terms of support for Trump during the
primary the more educated younger
Republicans were not the key voters for
Donald Trump Trump up ultimately won the
primary and the general election and
then we saw the younger and more
educated Republicans mostly rally behind
Trump probably a sort of you know listen
at least it's not Hillary we are
Republicans so we'll rally behind Trump
but now it's that same group who seems
to be realizing that what Trump is doing
is not good for the
it's not good for anybody and approval
among Republicans with four-year degrees
down 12 points approval under four young
Republicans also down and we wonder why
Republicans hate education so much right
it's funny to me that before the
election pollsters would point out
accurately if you're more educated
you're less likely to support Trump and
many Republicans would respond and say
Oh elitist that's that elitist left-wing
stuff even former disgusting
Pennsylvania Republican senator Rick
Santorum knows that it's true that the
more educated are not the key
demographic of Republicans here's Rick
Santorum in a famous clip we will never
have the elite smart people on our side
because they believe they should have
the power to tell you what to do
so our colleges and university they're
not going to be on our side so the proof
is in the pudding this proof is in the
pudding and why is this important to
understand it explains a lot of
right-wing hostility to higher education
because it actually relates to their
ability to have public support and get
things done it's not a question of
smearing Republicans as uneducated we're
merely pointing out that among
Republicans if you're more educated
you're less likely to support Trump and
that makes perfect sense and I wonder if
this demographic change will affect the
results of the 2020 election because as
some of these young and more educated
Republicans get older we're only talking
about four years but also we're talking
about a presidential race that is
decided between maybe a few percentage
points maybe tens of thousands of votes
so as they become more of a significant
part of the voting base does that mean
that they made vote for another
candidate or may stick host a home
altogether well I've talked about the
numbers around this and unfortunately
even with 33 percent approval and
younger Republicans moving away from
Trump and more educated Republicans
moving away from Trump Trump can still
win even with 33 percent approval Trump
can win reelection because remember only
about half the country voted and only
about half of them voted for Trump so
25% of eligible voters voted for Trump
if he has a 33
percent national approval rating sadly
Donald Trump can still win reelection
and this is why we've got to activate
2017 special elections talked about Roy
Moore yesterday 2018 midterm elections
don't wait around waiting for the 28
percent approval rating which will take
down Trump because even with those very
low approval ratings Trump can still win
let's take a break I'll speak to Rachel
Sherman next today's program made
possible in part by independent artist
types from Grand Rapids Michigan
bringing you the War II P it's a
progressive humanist multi-genre
response to the ongoing culture war in
America let's listen to a clip from the
song DARPA dogs
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I think multi-genre is right it
really does strike me initially sort of
as alternative but you can hear a lot of
other stuff in it and you can hear this
song in its entirety at types that's
types with forties VanCamp dot-com you
can also find exclusive demos and live
recordings on the types patreon and
YouTube pages both of which also spell
types with forties